so um to kind of recap we're going to
talk about how to get started and really
engage in this presentation
uh then we are going to talk about the
branding and benefits and then we'll
talk about the other side of linkedin so
most people know
um linkedin as a online resume
or a place for you to build your profile
but there's an entire other side in an
area that we're going to focus on today
that can expose you to
a lot of different opportunities that
you may not have been aware of
previously
then we're going to talk about curating
your timeline for learning so that first
piece of the the webinar we're talking
about becoming a better mentor
and then we're going to learn how you
can kind of repurpose your knowledge as
it relates to
content creation as well as being
recognized as a subject matter expert
which could really improve your job
search chances
as well as if you are a freelancer and
are looking to create additional income
this will be a great resource for you to
utilize for that as well
we'll talk about linkedin posting
suggestions because i see a lot of
people
will post and then they'll get
discouraged because they don't get any
engagement
and there are a lot of reasons for that
we'll talk about that um and then we'll
have an
activity to kind of close out before we
do some q a and answer some questions
from you all um
and then closing statements as well so
uh yeah without further ado
let let's go ahead and jump right into
today's content
so um as far as the the guide to
participation goes these are a couple
things i want you all to consider so if
you could
i see that several of you have turned
your microphones and your
um your cameras on thank you so much
for uh doing that i would ask that you
keep your microphones muted
um unless unless you're speaking but
um i also want to be able to see you all
so that we can engage better
it's also great for building community
and for you all to network with each
other
i know that you have access to speak to
each other through student hub channel
but this is a great opportunity as well
one bullet point that i like to mention
is that if you let me i will talk for
this entire time
um and if you want that then that's okay
but i do want to get some engagement
from you all i do want
this to be an integrative experience and
then the last thing is something that i
always want to make very clear
with the udacity students as well as
anybody who
may not you know have english as their
first language
a lot of times i have to coach my
students through the fact that like this
is not a disadvantage for you
and this should not necessarily be an
insecurity as well this is an advantage
that you can utilize in your job search
and so i also want you to feel
comfortable sharing with this group this
is a safe space for you to
ask questions to where there isn't going
to be any judgment nobody's going to
critique
your background or your microphone
quality or your
um your english speaking ability that's
not what we're here to do we're here to
help and
build community through you all so
that's kind of what i want to focus on
today
in terms of our guide to participation
um but yeah
let's jump in and i want to hear again
from you
so what i want to know is what does
personal branding mean to you
and if you feel comfortable feel free to
jump on your microphone
as well and if you don't i may ask you
to from the chat
so um if you feel comfortable feel free
to unmute yourself and speak up
i don't have any concerns that too many
people are going to jump on it once yeah
go ahead
uh yeah so i think personal branding
like in relations
to to this would for me mean like kind
of
uh um that people
on the one hand uh learn to uh i mean
associate you with a certain kind of uh
like product or uh in that uh
kind of uh in that this space right here
as if in the field right
um and so and i feel that
when we're talking about personal
branding it goes a bit into
the direction of diversification um
uh yeah so yeah pretty much okay
yeah thanks alex thanks for sharing
anybody else want to jump on their
microphone and share
okay
what you can do what your expertise
on so they know
what you can do to help them
in their projects i think this is an
important thing
yeah absolutely thank you for sharing i
see in the chat
irina says what people say about you
when you leave the room
absolutely or when you're not ever in
the room to begin with
so obviously with the pandemic we're not
fully able to kind of jump in and
you know share our own experiences with
people in person so
um what i was talking to a group about
today is really your only presence
is your online presence these days um so
uh it's really important that you
develop this because people
don't have the luxury of being able to
necessarily meet you in person at a
networking event or meet you at an
information session
or anything like that so your online
presence is extremely important these
days
and so pratik says someone types the
name on google and they find me that's
personal branding so yeah
that is definitely an aspect of that and
i think by
putting more of your work and your
expertise out there
it allows you to be more likely to
populate in those google searches
even if you have more of a common name
which is
a huge concern for some of us my name is
not extremely popular
but there is a famous author with a name
very close to mine so sometimes when you
search for that
his stuff pops up but i'm working very
very hard to take over his search
results
um so a great point um anybody else
yes brad like i just want to say i i
can't share my video but
anyway um i think sometimes this is a
disadvantage for people because
um for me as an introvert it's very hard
for me to engage on
social media networks and on linkedin
and create posts
and so yeah i mean i guess that's why
i'm here because
i want to learn some good practices yeah
no i definitely understand that uh that
concern i do think that
by focusing on like online branding it
allows you
it allows people who are introverted to
be a little bit more extroverted because
you're not necessarily having to
go into a room full of strangers or do
public speaking in front of a room of
people
it's a little bit of a different
experience so hopefully some of the
things that i'll share with you today
can
ease some of those worries um and i
think a lot of it just has to do with
getting started
and then you realize okay this isn't as
bad as i thought it would be or as
i'm not as nervous as i thought i might
be let's see there are two use how you
see yourself and how other people see
you so personal branding is related to
how people see you
that's a great way of describing it uh
what you are known for
yes larry says how you can convert
yourself to a brand
something with value cortica says how
you want to introduce yourself to the
world all of these are really great so
you guys have a really solid
understanding of what this is
um so oh one more mark says i would say
personal branding has to do with your
level of exposure on a community
what your works or solutions are known
for absolutely i think everybody kind of
hit
different areas of personal branding but
you all seem to get the gist of it so i
just pulled this
um this kind of quick definition so
nothing too fancy but uh this says that
personal a personal brand is a widely
recognized and largely uniform
perception or impression of an
individual based on their experience
expertise competencies actions and or
achievements within a community industry
or
the marketplace at large so yeah a lot
of you
almost kind of took the definition i
think and so it
shows me that you all have a solid
understanding of what this is
um defined so now let's talk a little
bit about
the actual benefits of it so the first
one is one of my favorites
so getting job offers without applying
so
this may seem a little bit idealistic
but in all reality
i was able to get this job with udacity
without ever applying
uh because of the the the my
well-developed profile because of the
content i was putting out on linkedin
i was able to draw the attention of not
only recruiters from udacity but other
places
um for career coaching opportunities and
people still reach out to me for those
um and so you know for a lot of you you
may be in a position where
you are serving as a mentor or reviewer
in
kind of a placeholder to kind of get
into the actual work that you want to do
um and so this can be a really great uh
strategy
within your job search to start getting
known for some of those
opportunities another thing that i love
about personal branding is that it can
potentially expose you to
earn additional sources of income for
your expertise
so i would have never thought that i
would be
kind of doing multiple different things
that are paying me in a sense to do the
exact same thing
so within what the work that i've been
able to do i'm able to get paid for
coaching through udacity
i'm able to get paid for coaching
through my business i'm able to get paid
to do writing
and get paid to do um kind of outside
private webinars and events
the cool thing is all of the content for
the most part is the same
so i'm able to recycle a lot of it and
get paid
multiple times from multiple different
sources for providing you know some of
the same content but just
uh presenting it in a way that's
targeted for those specific audiences
so with udacity my content is focused on
i t
within the um blog that i write for
that's kind of focused on um kind of
current working professionals so it's
less about job searching and more about
how to thrive in your current role
so with the knowledge that you have in
addition to
maybe being a web developer you could
also get paid to write for tech blogs
and talk about
the upcoming trends or things that
people should look out for
you may also get some opportunities to
teach classes for free or teach other
developers how to get started
so there are plenty of opportunities
that personal branding can expose you to
and obviously i'm not anywhere near
where i want to be but just looking back
on
when i really got started in linkedin
was only like three years ago
um and and i didn't have anybody like me
to guide me through that process i had
to learn as i went
so you may be able to kind of fast track
that process with some of this
information as well as if we
potentially do some events in the future
another thing which a lot of you also
might be um
entertaining and i'd love to hear go
ahead and drop in the chat if you're
also doing freelancing or anything on
the side to create some other income
uh because personal branding not only it
works kind of similarly to
how you're drawing attention from
employers you can also draw attention
from potential customers whether that is
you having a business to consumer
business
or a business to business business or
that kind of model there are multiple
ways where you can start drawing
attention
to where you don't have to be that
person always cold calling people
you're creating some passive lead
generation from
showcasing your expertise so there's a
benefit there as well
and then lastly this one is a little bit
less tangible but
being respected by industry leaders
sometimes that allows you to be asked
hey can you come serve on this panel
um hey would you like to speak at this
conference for
developers uh would you like to uh you
know
help me host an event for um machine
learning
you know these are these are things that
that can provide a lot of value in terms
of networking as well
so it can expose you to people who you
really really look up to are actually
reaching out to you and asking you for
help so
obviously this is not a very very quick
process
but it can happen quickly depending on
what spaces you're entering
and how intentional you are about that
process
so um i don't know if i saw anything in
the chat is anyone at all doing
any kind of freelance work or um
anytime has their own business or plans
to start one anytime soon
feel free to jump on the microphone as
well if you'd like
uh yes i'm working on a project right
now and hopefully
i'll get users to use it and see how it
goes
okay very cool so you can kind of tackle
this from two angles you can increase
your job search prospects as well as
draw customers for freelance business a
lot of the information is the same to do
both things
yeah anybody else
okay larry says udacity is for freelance
for him oh yeah go ahead alex
uh yeah i uh i was part of a um joint
venture
um a while ago and uh now uh
while i intend to uh continue to
uh to build competitions
in uh yeah my it consulting works
i also um having a look if i want to
start a business with partners right now
with two partners okay
yeah very cool so hopefully you'll gain
some insight for that as well
for that like branding is very important
i think like for
uh yeah yeah especially if you're
starting out right
you need to increase the awareness of
what you're doing for people to even
respect
or seriously consider paying you for
your work
yeah yeah i mean like yeah it's like a
physical product so like a food
uh um startup basically
um that we're looking at right now so um
yeah so that's definitely a
big part i think yeah okay very cool
yeah i see
uh john uh says that he works in the
live event space so the
down it's been tough man i get it i
actually had like a full
five-part workshop series with georgia
state university
and that got completely cancelled um
obviously
i took some time to pivot and figure out
what's going on in the market and
transition that to virtually
obviously that's not realistic with
every single type of live event but i
definitely understand it can relate to
that um let's see an ios business
leadership coaching um very cool
okay awesome so let's keep moving uh
wait let's see one more uh
khalid said i have a startup in
self-driving vehicles low speed vehicles
golf carts
very cool um so yeah hopefully you all
gain some benefits for this outside of
just uh
job seeking so um now i want to do kind
of a live demo and showcase to you
how i navigate linkedin um outside of
just my profile so give me one second
and i think i also need to
share uh let me see oh yeah i can share
that same screen
okay so um so yeah obviously this is
kind of
the home page everybody give me a thumbs
up if you can see this okay
okay great um so yeah this is basically
your your home page what comes up when
you log
into linkedin if you're not fully
familiar i'll do kind of some basics
um so yeah this is kind of showcasing
who you are you can go to your profile
from there um but when i'm logging in i
usually log into linkedin every morning
i usually do it while i eat breakfast so
that it's kind of part of my routine and
part of a habit
and i will go through and i'll read
these read the news here so
the reason why i think this is important
is that you know it helps you to stay on
top of the industry in general so
i oftentimes will get you know job
search advice a lot of it's a little bit
dated to me a little bit you know things
that we should have been knowing
a year or two ago but some of it is new
some of it talks about
different startups and businesses you
see a lot of stuff on here about like
google and amazon and
who's hiring but this is really great
for me also for things like
potentially investing in stocks you can
kind of see how certain businesses are
doing what's on the rise
i know there was a lot of conversation
on here about wework and different
businesses with models like that and so
outside of just your career it kind of
helps you stay
up to date with business in general
which most places that people work
are businesses um even if they're
non-profit they still operate as a
business so it's just helpful to know
that information
outside of that uh your timeline is
something that you can curate and that's
one of the things that i mentioned
before
you want the things that are showing up
in your timeline
to be relevant to things that you're
interested as well as your own uh
personal
career uh branding platform so
you want to be sure if you are a mentor
for
machine learning you want your timeline
to be related to machine learning data
science artificial intelligence
um and if you are uh for digital
marketing this is a great tool and
oftentimes i'm coaching
students who are studying digital
marketing in the fact that like
they don't even know how linkedin is
utilized and that's a huge marketing
tool i think it's one of the
top uh lead generation platforms for
business to business
so it's a great platform to learn for
for digital marketing in really any area
so as i kind of scroll through my
timeline usually do this a couple of
times a day
you will see posts um from certain
people
so when it comes up in your timeline
it's either someone who's a first
connection
which is a someone that you're actually
connected to like they sent a request or
you sent a request and it was accepted
you also may see things on your timeline
that second connections post so you'll
only see posts from like first
connections and second connections and
sometimes ads
but this is really important to know as
we start talking about creating content
because justin posted whatever this is
um and i would have never seen this
content
if it wasn't for monique and david who i
am connected with
who actually engaged with this content
so that's why
when and we'll talk about this a little
bit later but when you create content
you want it to be engaging you want
people to
like and comment it because then that
exposes you to their network
whereas a platform like uh instagram
you have to kind of be following someone
to see their content
unless you go to the explore page but
this is kind of the main home page so it
exposes your work to potentially a lot
of people
so you don't want to just put out boring
content to show that you're an expert
you want to make it engaging
you want to try to almost build your own
uh community uh we have a couple of
questions before we move forward
uh how can you build personal branding
on linkedin posting stuff and your
employer sees it it kind of signals that
you're looking for something else
so i think that that's a little bit more
of an old school mentality i think
if you're putting on your profile that
you're open to work or looking for work
i think that's different
than you posting on your timeline
sharing best practices
as a mentor or sharing best practices
for software engineering
that doesn't indicate to me that someone
is job searching that indicates to me
that someone is interested in building
their personal brand
i'm going to share my own personal
opinion if my employer had an issue with
that i would not want to work for them
um i obviou i understand obviously that
you know we're not on a situation where
we can
you know put put our jobs at risk that's
not what i'm saying
um i do think that that's very minimal
for someone to try and critique
um especially if you are job searching
that they should be supportive of that
but i understand not every situation is
like that
um alessio says how do you find the
premium feature for your profile
so my honest opinion i would not have it
unless
um you have a business or using it for
entrepreneurial perspectives
as a job seeker i don't think it's worth
the money it's like 60 bucks a month
but you do get access to things like
linkedin premium so for me it's a
business expense i would never
come out of pocket for that as a job
seeker but that's not to say that you
wouldn't find value
out of it i just think that that's you
know that's like
four times more than a netflix
subscription and i get much more value
out of that
um let's see uh recruiters aren't
replying despite sending a good message
what can i do about that so let's
hold off that question i want to make
sure that we stay on topic but
uh please bring up that question again
later if i'm not if i don't answer it
throughout the presentation
so um one thing that i like to mention
about linkedin especially as you're
navigating kind of your timeline and as
you are reading the news
to me logging into linkedin every day is
like
going to a conference you have people
who are industry experts who are sharing
their knowledge
it's an opportunity for you to learn as
well as like read the news and figure
out what's
trending in your industry so for me i
get so much value out of this platform
even as a passive learner so if if you
only take that from this session i think
it's still worth it to just use it to
stay
on top of your industry and obviously
you want to make sure that you're
following the right people
and connected to the right people so
make sure that you are curating your
timeline
if you're starting to like certain
things then those things are going to
start to populate more so
with this person um tristan walker
he's a founder and ceo of bevel um which
is a
which was like a men's grooming product
and i've actually seen him speak live
and i really enjoyed
that so whenever he posts things even if
i don't necessarily fully read it i know
that i like his content and i want more
of that to show up on my screen
so different things as it relates to
career coaching job searching
education technology those are things
that i'm passionate about
and things that i've built a career
around um so that's
why um those things are populating on my
timeline and if there
are certain things that might be a
little bit irrelevant i would probably
choose not to engage with that so i
don't see more of it but
one of the things that i would highly
encourage that you all do is
um make sure that you're connecting with
other people in your industry
so if you go to your my network tab
you can start to see
people and they'll give you
recommendations right so they'll give
you recommendations based on
you know people who are doing similar
work uh people who may have gone to the
same university as you
maybe other people who have completed
nano degrees i don't know if they've
gotten that specific
but you can also search for that
privately but this is a really good
area for you to look to start finding
content experts and industry leaders
and then when you go to their profiles
start to see if they actually create
content
so if you were to go to my profile
one of the things that you might want to
check and this is always slow when i
screen share
um but if you were to go to my profile
and you were to scroll
a little bit down
you could see that i have created some
content on linkedin
but you can also see in my activity
things that i have done recently so if
you find an industry expert and you go
to their activity page and you don't see
anything chances are
they're not very active but you can also
go to see all and you can see okay
brett commented on a post this morning
and one yesterday he's probably pretty
active this is somebody who's worth
following
and then you can look at the content
that they've posted in the past as a way
to kind of see if this is a good person
worth connecting with so
i wanted to share that just briefly in
terms of how i personally navigate the
homepage
because i do think that it's a really
great opportunity for you to
engage not only with people in your area
of expertise
but i think it's all there's it's also a
point that i wanted to make for you all
to
engage with other people like yourself
people who are mentors people who are
you know software engineering
instructors people who
um may potentially do the same exact
thing that you do but maybe for a
company like flatiron school or general
assembly or thinkful
all of these like coding boot camps that
are upcoming you can connect with other
people who are in similar situations as
you
um because that can be a really great
networking opportunity as well
so um let me see i know that there were
a couple
more comments and questions uh let's see
oh yes that this is definitely being
recorded so it will be shared with you
all
um as well as those who weren't able to
attend after
okay so let's jump back into the
presentation
hi brad sorry oh yeah go ahead i have a
question
sure so my question is
how to highlight our performance as
independent contractors in udacity as a
mentor
and as a reviewer in our resume and also
in our linkedin uh profile and also
i don't know how could udacity give us
the stats of our
about our performance that displays our
dedication
and efforts toward performance for
students
yeah that's a good question i personally
won't be able to answer that
uh go ahead alex no i also wanted to say
that that's very good
question um because like all the time
spent as a reviewer is maybe something
that
we would really benefit from have kind
of a proof of work because everybody
wants to uh
um see a proof of work at some point so
um
yeah so that's why i just wanted to add
that it's a very good question
okay yeah i think it's definitely
something um so that's not necessarily
my area but i think it's something that
you can bring up with the
um with your leadership team um i know
from the the coaching side there is some
that we do to get feedback
from students but one thing i do want to
make note of is like regardless of
udacity or wherever you work that should
always be a habit of yours to do on your
own
and find ways for you to be able to
document your experience
so obviously as it relates to student
feedback you probably don't want to set
up your own system
but just get in the mindset of how you
can do that in general
is really important because those are
things that i showcase on my linkedin or
things that i showcase on my resume
is kind of my um coaching you know
satisfaction score in a sense um but in
previous positions
that was never provided to me and so um
in previous positions i had to actually
find ways to showcase my work
outside of that so i would just
encourage you to kind of also brainstorm
and reflect like outside of them
tracking that
what are some other ways that i can
document my experience and you bring up
a good point because the main goal is
for you to be able to showcase your
impact
that's hugely important as it relates to
a job search but also for asking for
raises promotions
salary negotiation those things can
really be beneficial so yeah i
definitely um
i know that bree's on here so she's
aware that that's something that you are
looking
uh looking for so it's probably
something that they'll want to explore
but outside of that i would highly
encourage that you look for things
outside of that as well
so that you're tracking your own
experience uh but yeah
great question and the cool thing about
that is like as you're documenting that
experience you can use that
outside of just um your resume and your
linkedin profile those are also things
that you can use to create content
around
um one of the things i encourage people
to do as they create content is
it's okay to brag you know it's okay to
brag one of the things that i would say
is the the approach that i take is brag
and teach
if i'm gonna brag i'm always gonna add
something of value to someone else
so if i'm gonna say look at me i just
finished this certificate program
i'm also going to add five tips for
anyone else who's interested in learning
about that topic
so that way you know people as they're
scrolling through the timeline
you might get it you might get 5 000
likes for finishing a phd program but
that doesn't mean you're going to get
any follows
but if you are someone who kind of posts
look at this i just completed this
nanodegree
um here are the five things that i
learned or if you're interested in
udacity here are my top five tips for
making the most out of your experience
that's something that people would want
to follow you for if you start posting
uh similar content
uh let's see
is it a good idea to let employer know
that i'm working at udacity along with
my full-time job will they be
comfortable with that is it going to
affect my interview
so i think if you are it's a tough
it's a tough question to answer i don't
think that i have the right answer i
don't think that i've
navigated that well in the past i know
that a lot of employers
want you to be solely focused on that
job
and that's not something that i can
coach you around like you're dealing
with people people have their own set of
um biases they have their own set of
you know experiences and things that you
know alter their judgment and so
it's hard to give you a right answer for
that um
i think the important thing is for you
to
focus on employers that are going to be
supportive in whatever you do
i know that you know if this is contract
if this is freelance it could be
beneficial to mention but it could also
be
a negative thing to mention depending on
who you're talking with
and then yes magdie says some contracts
prevent you from doing that
uh definitely um i think it also you
know some companies have non-competes
that you have to check very critically
to see if it's in conflict with what
they're doing
um but yeah all great questions uh so
yeah this is what i wanted to talk about
um
in terms of creating the actual content
so we touched on it very briefly
about okay i want to create content
where do i get started
so this is a very common question that i
get from people who are kind of worried
about getting started you know what do i
say
i don't feel comfortable writing an
article here are some things that i
would encourage you to think about
so i'm sure you all can kind of attest
to this that when you're talking with
students or you're reviewing questions
or you're reviewing projects
they're the same issues that are coming
up over and over and over is that
is that accurate is that true
is that something that you all
experience kind of seeing the same
mistakes
feel free to hop on your mic because i
might have a follow-up question
okay so yes yes sure uh
let me see harisu if you feel
comfortable or
alvaro or anybody who who said yes jump
on your mic i want to know what's the
most common issue that you get from
students
all the time yes who wants to share
hi brad so um well i don't remember
exactly
what but yeah i do i do know that there
are some really frequent questions
so what i actually did was creating like
a blog post
on medium okay and like before
there were like um like the knowledge
was like a
very powerful tool and uh students did
not use it that much
so i created that like frequent ask
questions blog posts and yeah
like i get a lot of likes yeah and i
think that that that's great too because
it saves you all time
right so creating content has saved me a
tremendous amount of time and it's
something that i didn't realize as a
direct result
so one cool thing about it is like when
i have coaching calls
usually my first call with students is
focused on creating a plan
because most people have no plan for
their job search they're just applying
applying applying applying and hoping
that something sticks and that's not an
effective strategy so usually our first
call is focused on that
and then our second call is usually
focused on it used to be focused on
going through their linkedin profile and
what i found was that i was
like a broken record and i was getting
really bored of walking people through
the same basics
and so i created a linkedin webinar
that is focused on um putting together
your linkedin profile so after that
first coaching call
i could say i want you to watch this so
that in our second call we can go
through your profile together and we're
not starting from scratch
because you'll need time to think and
reflect and write which is not conducive
to a 30-minute phone call
so do that in the meantime so that you
have
something to work on in in that that
space on your own which is more
conducive for you to do on your own so
that we can be more productive
so sometimes creating that content is
really helpful in saving you
and students time when they're not able
to have a direct one-on-one conversation
uh
so yeah i see how do i get an internship
with your company uh how to start my app
so those are content ideas those are
things that you can potentially write
about that i think people would really
find value in
um and i think you you definitely want
to check with the
leadership team to ask if it's okay for
you to share your outside content
that's something that you want to make
sure is clear first before you even do
that
but another thing that you could do is
just simply say
you know what follow me on linkedin i
have some resources there that you might
find valuable
um or say follow me on linkedin i'm
usually posting about this topic
if you can't get around that but i would
say make sure you double check with that
to see if that's okay first
um so yeah another question what's the
biggest mistake you see
beginners make often times with udacity
we're dealing with beginners
we're dealing with people who are
starting from scratch or transitioning
careers entirely
and so those common mistakes to you
might seem
boring having to address them over and
over and trust me
i can relate um those are good that's
gold that's content gold because if
you have 20 udacity students who have
that issue
imagine how many people in the world are
having that issue that you could
potentially help solve for them and
people remember that there's a an
article that i wrote on linkedin
about how to write a cover letter that's
just taken off
it's not even my best one but it has
over 50 000 views
and there have been several people who
have said you know thank you so much for
sharing this bread this
article alone got me my job i can
guarantee you that when their friend
says
i really feel like i'm struggling i need
help with my resume or i need a career
coach
they're gonna think of who they're gonna
think of brett the guy who helped them
get a job even if they didn't hire me as
a coach
so it also helps you stay top of mind
and be kind of known
top of mind for your area of expertise
and what you really want to be known for
um and as alvaro mentioned he wrote that
article on
medium you could very easily copy and
paste that article and put it on
linkedin
i have most of my articles on both
platforms
and i get you know i get a lot of google
search results from medium
but i get a lot of um like follows
from linkedin for the same type of
articles so i have um the cover letter
article does really well on medium as
well
um but then i have one that i created
that's like the ultimate guide to
remote and work from home jobs that i
created in 2018
and that one has skyrocketed since the
pandemic started so
you never know when your content could
potentially take off so it's helpful to
just create it because you can
always repurpose it that the funny thing
about that one specific article is that
i created a post on linkedin and i said
hey career coaches i'm looking for
advice i see that people are more
interested in this idea of working
remotely and working from home
what's the deal with that basically and
this was two years two and a half years
ago
so i got like 70 comments people who are
career coaches
tech recruiters who had been working
remotely for 10 plus years
and what i did was i transitioned all of
those comments
into the guide and i tagged each and
every single one of those people
so guess what they're going to want to
do hey check out this article i was
featured in and then you have like
20 plus people who are sharing my
article just because they're in it
and that boosts the awareness
tremendously and all i really did was
kind of compile all of their comments
and put it in an order that made sense
and i credited every single one of them
so
there's a win-win-win for that you know
the contributors win
i win and the viewers win and i always
try to operate in that mindset as it
relates to
um you know creating content i think
it's important to think about
and so just a couple of content um
channels that i i want to share linkedin
obviously if you have a blog
or you have medium articles very easy to
transition that to linkedin
one thing that i usually remind people
about is you know a lot of people say
you know i started this blog i have like
four articles on it
realistically how many views are you
getting on that blog
unless you send someone a direct link
right i don't think you know there may
be a couple of you in here who have very
successful blogs but i think for the
most part people who have blogs
don't get as much views or engagement as
they want and that tends to cause them
to quit
whereas a platform like linkedin you're
getting a lot of passive traffic just
from keyword searches
and so that can really boost the
visibility there even if you've already
created it somewhere else even if it's
two years old
write it in a way that's current for now
and make it to where
it makes sense for your audience
let's see uh most beginners directly
jump into advanced topic without knowing
basic prerequisites
gotcha yes um that's a good point and i
think that that's something that you
could create content around and saying
you know if you're interested in getting
into the field of data science i highly
recommend that you take this specific
online course that you found
elsewhere udemy.com take this and then
if you're
comfortable with that and feel confident
move on to this udacity nanodegree that
takes it a step
further um and then beyond that you'll
need to gain experiences like this this
and this for employers to take you
seriously
so that's content gold so you all have
kind of these ideas that are just kind
of in here
and you're using it when you're
responding to questions you're using it
when you're grading projects you're
using it when you're talking to students
but it's not being repurposed to a place
that i think benefits you even more and
so
when it comes to creating content a lot
of it you can get rid of a lot of that
intimidation
from saying i'm not sitting down for an
hour and writing something from scratch
i'm just repurposing what i've already
used and what i've already done
in multiple different ways so to me
i'm trying to create as many different
sources of income as i can doing the
same thing
i think that that's ideal because it
saves time if i have
you know a full day of coaching i could
still do a webinar
at the end of the day i can still write
an article and a lot of that
allows me to have multiple sources of
income for basically this the same
knowledge so um i do think that there's
ways that you all can
incorporate that into your own current
situation
sorry yeah go ahead go ahead i have a
question um sure i think
like uh that was really good advice you
know how to
i don't know know what content to write
especially for
students but what about if you know
maybe the audience is not a student and
i don't know it's like
human resources directors or something
and they don't
like ask questions on linkedin and those
kind of things so
what would be i don't know like the
strategy to to know what to write
if there are no questions great that
yeah that's that's a great question i
think
if you're going to create content on
linkedin the point is to educate people
so they don't necessarily have to be
udacity students they don't necessarily
have to be students in general
but i think if you posted something i
could learn from it
if i posted something you can learn from
it and when you engage with that
i'm sorry it just creates more awareness
of what you're doing
so even if you're not creating content
for hr managers or recruiters
those people still have potential to see
that because people that they're
connected to
are constantly engaging with the stuff
that you're writing
i would never target recruiters for
content i don't think that that's
ideal because that really limits you to
you know a job search you don't want to
make it about like hire me hire me hire
me it's like
i know what i'm doing this is how i know
what i'm doing i have
30 people who have commented on here and
78 likes
people know that i can do this work and
so those they're just being exposed
to your work and potentially going to
your profile and then from there they're
sitting there and evaluating
okay he has experience doing this he has
experience doing that
he's showcased some things from his
portfolio on his profile
it's just adding to that level and level
and level of credibility
but also the more connections that you
have the easier it is for people to find
you in those keyword searches as well
so i do think it's extremely important
for you to know what your audience is i
think
it's always smart to target you know
people who want to learn from you
but also industry experts and i think
through those two things
recruiters will come i don't think that
you have to specifically create your
content for them i think that they will
come because
they're constantly on linkedin looking
for talent
but yeah um annie here so
i'm sorry that i insist on this but um
as an introvert
all of you have said scares me okay so
at this point
it is mandatory to have linkedin and all
these evaluations made
it means that the industry and the job
search dismisses my professional
background and skills because i don't
engage with social networks
so um what is a best practice or like
are you saying
is this mandatory is this what i have to
do
or like how how does someone how how
does a company
approach someone um introverted like me
am i instantly dismissed or what does it
mean
so no i think with a lot of the things
that i'm sharing it can sometimes come
across as mandatory
but i'm the type of person to say you
know these are the things that you can
do to really stand
out um so in terms of creating content
and engaging on linkedin
that's not necessary i think it can add
to it i think what you really want to
focus on is having a very very high
quality
keyword searchable profile and you can
still experience a lot of success
through that
you know when we're talking about like
um content creation that's kind of next
level
but um let me um give when i get a
chance
i will find the link and if brie if you
can do that that would be super helpful
on the udacity
youtube page if you go to the career
webinars playlist
there if you scroll through it and you
guys can do this as well but there
we have a ton of videos um for students
but you can take advantage of them as
well it's open to the public there's one
that i facilitated called
the linkedin guide to landing jobs
without applying and it's really focused
on
putting together a keyword optimized
focused profile
so i would encourage you check that one
out because i do think that you could
still experience a lot of success
with just making sure that you have a
high quality profile
it's just that a lot of the stuff that
we're talking about today just goes in
alignment with
personal branding and becoming a better
mentor and we already have that content
available so this is kind of a
new kind of if you wanted to take it to
the next level but we do have some of
those pre-recorded resources that you
can take advantage of
okay so yeah some of the the things here
the the content
ideas um some of these content ideas are
similar to some of the other things
but um ask yourself these questions
these are very easy ways to get started
in terms of creating maybe your first
linkedin post maybe this is the first
time you've ever done it
however you have me to guide you through
this so
you're starting at a much better place
than i did um but just try it
see what happens you never know um
people might see it
they might engage with it it might
encourage you to keep going with it so
um ani if if it does make you nervous i
would say
give it one try or two tries um and just
see how it works if you're not
comfortable
comfortable with it you don't ever have
to do it again um oh
thank you thank you uh brianna yeah
absolutely this is this is not necessary
but i think as the job market continues
to shrink right like there are just less
opportunities available
you really need to be seen you need to
stand
out you need to be recognized and i
think that you know sometimes people are
uncomfortable with that attention
which i can totally you know get to the
main reason why i did this was to make
money
um to start personal branding to
building my business
you know i i'm the type of person i'd
rather be rich than famous like that
makes me worried if i was to get up to
that level
um because i like my anonymity i like to
remain unknown a little bit but i know
that i have a lot of information that
can help people
and so me as an educator i also have i
feel like i have a responsibility to
share my knowledge
so it's never really been about
becoming well known it's more so been
about i have all this stuff in my head
that i've taken time to learn why not
share that and give that back to other
people who could really benefit from
this
but yeah i definitely understand your
worries i think that this is a good
opportunity for
introverts whereas more of the in-person
stuff it can be a little bit more
difficult but i still understand if you
have some issues with that
um totally understandable uh michael
says
uh do you have any advice for people who
seek remote work outside of the country
they are in
yes um it's tough it's tough right now i
think remote roles were highly
competitive pre-covered
i think that they're even more
competitive now
even though they're more available i
think that you want to try to connect
with people at those companies
in advance before positions become
available so one mistake that i see a
lot of people make is they'll
you know i see a job i want to work as a
machine learning engineer at this
company
in the uk and i see a job and then i'll
go to linkedin find somebody who works
there and then reach out
and say hey love to learn about your
experience or hey i see that you just
posted a job
but to some people on the receiving end
it becomes
this person is only reaching out to me
so they can get a job and
when you approach it from a transit
transactional
approach it takes away from the ability
to build genuine relationships
and so if you want to find a remote job
i highly suggest that you start by
creating a list of companies first
that you're interested in and then build
those relationships proactively so that
when positions do become available
you can pull on those relationships and
that may you may think to yourself
well what if they never post one
then they don't but what i'm saying is
that's a much more effective process
you're more likely to build genuine
relationships
you're more likely to get referrals and
that's why you don't focus on one two or
three companies
you might have a list of 10 15 that
you're reaching out and building
connections in advance
and then monitor monitoring those
companies job alerts
but then also maintaining and building
those relationships so that
they know what you're looking for and
may potentially even say you know
hey michael we're hiring for this role i
think that you'd be perfect for it
please send me your application so i can
forward it to the hiring manager
that seems ideal but i promise you it
happens
when you're doing it right it happened
to me very recently
um and i think it's more so about when
you're looking for people to connect
with
i always tell my students ask yourself
can i see myself having a professional
relationship with this person
if it never leads to a job at this
company if your answer is no
you can still reach out but i think
ideally you want to say yes
because that helps you go about it a
different way it helps you to find
people who have similar interests which
you know answers the question in the
chat how do you build those
relationships i think you start
by building in with people that you have
things in common with
so you can search linkedin for
udacity people who have udacity in their
education section
you can filter by that and see all the
people who have completed nanodegrees
you can use that as a way to introduce
that conversation you can use that as a
way to start
talking how is your experience um i work
as a reviewer for this program i'd love
to learn about your experience so i can
better
my role as a reviewer or as a mentor um
what did you think about the projects
you know those are things that you can
use to start a conversation
and ultimately i think with you know
building those relationships you
always want to make sure that it's
mutually beneficial
so i usually try to avoid people who i'm
just reaching out to because i want
something from them
i always am trying to constantly ask
myself how can i provide value to them
as well and i think that you know
the conversation between me and bree is
a testament to that right
i was just connecting because i was like
you know bri
um works for udacity this would be a
great idea a great opportunity for me to
just network
internally and we started to have a
conversation and it was like how can we
help each other
and i think that this is a perfect
example of how you do that and how you
build those relationships and so
through this process i would hope that
brie would look out for me
and i would look out for her if i knew
what she was looking for and i could
recommend her in the future
that's how you build relationships
because it's not one-sided
and i think that that would change your
entire
approach to networking in general is
trying to focus on building genuine
relationships
and focusing on how you can make it
mutually beneficial
um i think is it it has definitely
changed the dynamic for me to where i'm
not approaching it from a means to an
end
i'm genuinely approaching it from like i
would like to get to know this person
and figure out how we can help each
other um i think that that will help you
um so yeah in terms of content ideas
what else can you guys think of
that that you think might be helpful or
that you've been thinking you know i
want to create something around this but
i haven't necessarily known how to go
about
doing it um what are some things that
you all
might think could be good content ideas
for you and and also please share
specifically
um the content area so whatever your
your coaching or mentoring around
yeah i think for me um
creating content around career
transition from
live events into uh machine learning or
software engineering would would
probably be right up my alley for like
targeting those executives that are
trying to fill those positions
um because then it hits both industries
it hits you know the tech
industry and live event professionals so
yeah no absolutely and i think you'd be
surprised how many people you're able to
help
because even if they haven't worked in
the live event industry they may have
been a bartender
or they may have made their living
around being in person
and so i think that a lot of people will
will gain
clarity from from from what information
that you share
and sometimes people just want to hire
people that are helpful
so if they see that you're on here
helping people providing content
and not asking for anything in return
they may be
more likely to say we should hire this
person because we want people like that
to work for us so yeah
that you you'll be surprised as you go
through this process
who you gain as supporters who are
people that that really want to get
involved and who
recommend you to other people there have
been several times where i have
you know booked coaching calls and asked
you know how did you find out about me
they say oh so and so recommended me i'm
like i don't even know who that is
so you know there are a lot of benefits
from just being a helpful person and i
think people want to help
people who help people but yeah any
other content ideas
uh yeah for me i'm khaled and i'm
working in
self-driving vehicles but at the same
time people think that
this is the only thing that i know so
maybe i can post other things for
example
python and how to
tips and tricks on using python so
this would increase an area that is hazy
for others to understand
how good or how much i know about it
yeah so one thing to just keep in mind
with that is that
you don't want to you don't want to kind
of make it unclear what your area of
expertise is
so i think some of those things are
really helpful but if your focus is like
self-driving car and that's what you
want to be known for you don't want to
be talking about things that are
too far unrelated i think obviously this
is right in alignment
but just something for everybody to
think about that's one of the big
challenges that i've had is that
i've been career coaching my entire
career but i'm ready for the next step
like i want to lead teams i want to
manage a budget like i'm ready to go
um and so it's been a little bit
challenging for me to to continue to
create content around
job searching and career development
because i want to focus more on people
who are
kind of looking to move up not people
who are looking to like
land a new role i want to help people
develop leaders
i'm interested in education and tech and
so sometimes
my varied interests have helped but
sometimes they've also hurt because
people are like well you can't be good
at everything like you you where are you
where are you focusing on
um unfortunately we're kind of in a job
market where these employers they want
specialists
and especially if you're looking at like
those major companies these are not
startups where you're
doing all kinds of different things
you're wearing multiple hats a lot of
times it's like
we want you to focus on this one project
we want you to maintain it
and we want you to be good at that and
that's it and for me i struggle with
that because i want to do events i want
to do coaching i want to manage a budget
i want to do all these different things
and sometimes that
um works in my favor but it also works
against me in some cases
uh yeah let's uh kind of move
on so this is really important um if you
are interested in kind of creating posts
this is outside of articles i think
articles are kind of the next step
that's like a little bit more advanced
but
i will say this about articles even if
people don't read it
it still elevates you as an expert so if
people
see that you wrote an article on
uh best practices for predictive
business analytics
even if they don't read it they're like
wow this this this lady created an
article
um she must be smart she must know what
she's talking about
um and so that alone can kind of boost
your credibility but then obviously
as you continue to go as you continue
that process you'll get better
for me i love being able to write on
linkedin
i i grew up hating writing i always
disliked it i didn't like the fact that
it was always critiqued i was like you
know this is my
expression why are they critiquing what
i'm trying to do
um and so for me it i write very
conversationally
i make grammatical errors i don't have
any editor who's coming in and saying
i think this sentence should be worded a
little bit differently you can write
whatever you want however you want the
grammar can be off
obviously you want it to make sense and
read easily but i
write very conversationally so if you
read an article from me
it would sound very similar to a webinar
or a one-on-one conversation
if you are interested in doing posts or
articles
and you're not super confident with kind
of writing it in english
grammarly is a really great resource i
use the free version there are also some
other free versions of that that will
kind of
critique your grammar as you write um or
you can copy and paste it into that
platform
to where it makes a little bit more
sense so i recommend that a lot of times
to
students who you know english is their
second language and they're trying to
write their resumes
but it applies here as well you want it
to be easily readable and sometimes if
there are too many grammar errors it can
be hard to read or
discourage people from continuing and i
see that there are some questions i want
to get through this
slide just really quickly so
these are my top tips so i'll go through
each one of them so
when you post on linkedin just kind of a
regular post not an article or anything
in depth
um usually as it pops up in the timeline
you only i think before you used to only
see the first three lines now i think
you see like the first five lines
but that's your chance to get them to
continue reading more so you want to
write something that's going to grab
their attention so
stories work really well um shocking
statistics work really well
um you want to be careful with the click
bait um
where you're kind of posting something
that's just to get them to read it and
then it's like well this isn't
this isn't even accurate so um things
that are shocking sometimes will get
people to read it especially because
it's on linkedin
so some of the ways that i've kind of
jumped in and led conversations it's
like
uh stop applying for jobs online like
that's a big
people like whoa wait a minute how am i
supposed to get a job and then
you know you provide the context and
give them some reason why
but always grab their attention because
it will encourage them to read more
two always always always add value and i
think that
you know that goes back to that
conversation we talked about when we
brag and teach
if you finished a nanodegree or got your
master's degree that's great
but you could have a million likes and
not get any follows or
any connections or any job opportunities
or any freelance customers through that
so you always want to add value because
that encourages people
to want to connect with you it it makes
it so that people
want to engage with you a little bit
more um
and and helps you to be in a position to
where
you can um be seen as a helper and as we
mentioned before
that's really impactful number three i
would say is to tag active users
so this is something you want to be
careful of you don't necessarily want to
tag people that you don't know
or tag people that you don't frequently
engage with
so you don't want to say you know here
are my top five job search tips
and then tag the top career expert in
the world
that's not something you want to do so
if there are people that you're
interested in engaging with
do that for them first so if there's
someone who's in your field who's a
thought leader who posts frequently on
linkedin
make a habit of liking and leaving
thoughtful comments on their page
so instead of just going in and liking
it and moving on or liking it and saying
thanks or this is great go in like it
and say
i love that you posted this i think this
would be extremely helpful for beginning
software engineers
if i would add anything to it i would
say to
make sure you know that you're going to
fail and fail and fail until you succeed
and once you get comfortable with that
you'll be able to be a developer or
something like that
so you want to add value again even when
you're engaging with other people's
obviously it's not always relevant but
as much as you can do that the better
because even if you're just engaging
with other people's content
you still have an opportunity to
showcase your expertise as well as
increase the awareness of their post so
once again where when when when
where if i'm posting and people are
engaging they have an opportunity to
build their awareness of what they're
doing if they're posting and i'm
commenting
i have the opportunity to do the same
but then at the end of the day the end
user the viewer are the ones who benefit
as well
so it's i love the platform for that
reason
um four i would say include relevant
hashtags um
when necessary it's not always necessary
but i would say
one to three do not go overboard like
people do on instagram
um include 20 different hashtags it
might help in terms of the visibility
but i think it takes away from the
quality of the the actual content so
only
include hashtags that are really
relevant to your posts so
if you post about self-driving cars
maybe your
hashtag is self-driving car autonomous
vehicles
artificial intelligence and leave it at
that don't go overboard and and
do too much the next thing is
readability is key
so what i mean by that is if you're
posting you have 1300 characters in
linkedin
if you're posting there and you're using
quite a bit of that
you don't want to put it all in one
giant block of text
as somebody scrolling through and seeing
that i'm going to say whoa that's too
much i don't want to read it even if
it's the same character amount right
so break it up into small sections to
where it's easily readable you can
include
emojis you can include like dashes or
bullets or things that make it
you know more visually appealing to the
eye and things that you know
lazy millennials and gen z people like
me get comfortable with
lists instead of reading paragraphs that
can be a really good way to encourage
people to want to continue reading
through that
um and the funny thing about it is the
posts that i create on linkedin that do
the absolute best
are full all the way to the end of the
character limit like purely long-form
text 1300 characters or close to it
which is surprising to me because
normally on social media things like
video and pictures
and other elements add to the visibility
but for me personally
just the long-form text works extremely
well because i'm able to
provide examples i'm able to share
stories and so that works really well
for me but
may not necessarily work well for you so
you have to take some time to refine
that and figure out
your situation number six is so
so so tremendously important so that
you're not wasting your time
so as it relates to when you post is
extremely important i see people who
will you know go and have an event um
and john you might be able to relate to
this but go and have an event
hire a videographer record the event pay
someone to edit it
and then post it on linkedin on a
saturday night
and it's like no nobody's on linkedin
right now nobody's on linkedin
on a saturday night you know i mean
depending on the time zone
but you want to post when people are
engaging and traditionally
on linkedin people are on linkedin at
work so during traditional
business work hours you know nine to
five ish
um for most people obviously now people
are on the internet a lot more so
weekend
fridays nights are a little bit more
engaging but that's the case with any
platform but
focus on when people are actually using
the platform so that you're not wasting
all of this time creating this amazing
content
and posting it at 10 pm where nobody's
gonna read it and maybe a couple people
will in the morning
that's not to say you can't have a
successful post at those times
but you're just better off doing it for
me and
and you all might have specific times at
work really well but i want to guess i
want you all to guess what's the best
time for me to post on linkedin
think about the work that i do and think
about what i do every day
i'll give you a hint it's a specific day
of the week
and a specific time of day not like a
1 p.m or but like morning afternoon
night on a specific day of the week
so someone farida says afternoon
dimitrios says
a little bit afternoon thursday
lunchtime before lunch so nobody's
gotten it yet
sunday night good guess 6 p.m so
okay let's think about the work that i
do right i help people find jobs that
they love
yes elena yes monday morning is the best
time for me to post when people are like
uh i have to get up and go through
another week of this nonsense
and then when i'm posting about how to
get to your next step people are already
in the emotional space to want to engage
or want to reach out and throw their
money at me obviously it doesn't happen
that easily
but it's a great time for me to post
because that's when people
really want to engage with what i'm
doing it may not be as clear for you
but i recommend that you take some tips
from the digital marketing reviewers in
here
and do some a b testing or see you know
post in the morning post in the
afternoon post at night post at lunch
post on monday tuesday wednesday you
know different
different tries and see what works the
best for you because
your audience is going to determine
how well your content does so keeping in
mind the timing is really important
i wish i had a prize to give you elena
um but yeah congratulations for guessing
that i guess
um but yeah keep in mind the timing is
extremely important so i did see that
there was
a question i want to get to so don't
miss it um
let's see let's see uh do you have any
advice when we are switching roles from
a software developer to a data analyst
um i think my biggest piece of advice
is to position your branding to where it
fits data analyst
now and not software developer a lot of
people will go the route
of saying software developer looking to
transition into a data analyst role
you don't want to do that you want to
say that you are a data analyst
looking or i'm sorry a data analyst with
a background in software development
obviously you don't want to call
yourself a data analyst if you don't
know how to do that work
but you also don't have to have that job
title to consider yourself that
so one example that i usually share with
people is like for me
in my business and most of the stuff
that i do even some work with udacity
i do my own graphic design and so if i
woke up tomorrow and said you know what
this career coaching stuff is boring
none of the people on the webinar ever
talk
i want to be a graphic designer i could
do that
because i have that skill set i know how
to shift my branding to match that
um but you have to be confident in that
skill set it's not necessarily that you
have to be hired for that role
before you can start calling yourself
that i think that there's a lot of power
in kind of
getting rid of that impostor syndrome
and telling yourself you know
i am this this is what i can do this is
what i'm good at and you're not going to
get people to believe in you and you're
not going to get people to be confident
in hiring you if you're not confident in
yourself
so you want to position yourself as a
data analyst with the background in
software development so
doing that on linkedin on your profile
as it relates to your resume
focusing on what elements of your
previous jobs as a software developer
qualify you to be a data analyst so
you're not just regurgitating job
descriptions
and saying i do this i do this i do this
i do this
you want to showcase how what you've
done is related to what you want to do
i'll give you another example so in one
of my previous positions i oversaw
a college dorm building and when i was
trying to make a transition into
career coaching i didn't focus on things
like
facilities and maintenance issues i
didn't talk about crisis response i
didn't talk about
roommate conflicts i chose to write my
resume in a way that focused on
the one-on-one supervision the hosting
educational programs
and being involved in the professional
and student staff hiring process
all of those things were still within my
role and my responsibilities
they may not have been the main things
that i was doing but that does a better
job of showcasing how i'm qualified to
be a career coach
whereas the facilities issues the crisis
response i would never do that
in a career coaching role so it makes no
sense to showcase that on my resume
because it's not appealing to their
needs you always have to consider the
company's needs the same way as a
business owner you need to consider your
customers needs
when you're putting out your marketing
materials which for you all
in the job search include your linkedin
profile and your application materials
uh let's see how many articles activity
do you post daily or weekly where do you
find content how do you
protect the content you create amazing
questions so
for me i used to post three times a week
when i was really trying to boost my
credibility um
now is a perfect time i just don't have
the time to do it um
it's just really tough for me to find
time to sit down and either create or
repurpose the content that i have
but at one point i was doing it three
times a week getting a lot of really
good engagement building my profile up
now is a great time because people are
stuck to their phones and always
consuming social media
there is no right way to do it i would
say for you
you have to think about what's realistic
for you to be able to do quality
and consistency so if you say i'm going
to
create one post a week i think that
that's an amazing place to start i think
that's very realistic for
anybody in this group you know myself
included it doesn't matter how busy you
are i think you could create one post
um obviously i don't know everybody's
situation but um that's a good goal at
least in getting started say i'm gonna
i'm gonna create one post a week at
least to see how this works to see if
this is something that i want to
continue doing
um how do i protect the content i create
i'm still figuring it out um i a lot of
times just
put out stuff for free and keep the more
what i would consider like gold content
for paid opportunities so even with
udacity like i give
some of the greatest content that i have
but i'm not gonna share
my best stuff um with this specific
platform unless i'm getting paid extra
to do so because i do
similar work with my business so um as
it relates to linkedin the same thing
goes i'm not going to post
a online course for free if i put
you know several you know hours into
that as a way to create income for
myself so i think you have to figure out
what content makes sense for free for
lead generation for
helping your audience and what makes
sense to save for
you know my one-on-one clients the
people who are paying me to do that the
people who
come to me for paid content so that they
say well why would i go and pay you to
do this if i can get it
through udacity's youtube page or
through your linkedin articles
um i want to pay you for the exclusive
stuff so you have to have a little bit
of both i think one for the awareness
and the marketing and then one to
provide that level of quality and
exclusivity to
um your potential audience but i think
if you're just job seeking
i i don't worry too too much about
protecting content because
at the end of the day all content is
stolen in my opinion
um i think you know this webinar
obviously i came up with it out of my
head
but all of these things i learned
through other linkedin users through my
own experience through books that i've
read through classes that i've taken so
at the end of the day
i don't think content belongs to anyone
for the most part i think you know
depending on how much work and effort
you put into it that does become your
own
but for me i don't like to monopolize my
knowledge i think that that's
unethical um especially in the work that
i do
uh one of my fears is that if i keep
writing content and get little to no
feedback then i don't know what's wrong
that's a very realistic possibility and
could happen
but at the same time there's the same
chance that it could go really well
so that that would be my only piece of
advice is it could go
um wrong but at the end of the day what
do you you don't lose anything
not even time because if you have
content as we talked about before you
can very easily repurpose that for other
things
uh you said it's better to focus on a
very specific field so that recruiters
know what is your exact area of
expertise does this hold for business
i i think so um if my goal is to get
customers to find me is is it
bad to be more general i think so i've
experienced that personally where i've
tried to
expand from um just doing resume writing
to then doing career coaching
that didn't do public speaking and then
to do webinars and workshops it has
become
a little cloudy i think for certain
people who are viewing my profile
and they're like well what are you what
are you good at and i'm like i can do
all of these things
but for the average person they may they
may not believe that from your profile
and so i personally believe that it is
better to focus
so for me i've thought about like you
know potentially creating a different
business just for the public speaking
versus the coaching
right now it's just hard for me to do
that as one person but i do think that
it helps you to have more of a niche in
a focus area
how much do you need to champion topic
or research in order to write about it
for example i'd love to i'd love the
importance of data analytics for the
develop of kovid but i'm not a biotech
expert
so i think you know focus on what you
know don't try to create content around
things that you're not an expert because
even if you're successful at writing it
will you be successful at answering
questions about it is is kind of my test
can i answer
questions related to this or find a
biotech expert and collaborate on a
project
that's kind of what me and brie are
doing with this i wouldn't have been
able to put this together
without her knowledge of what you all
are looking for and what your experience
is
as mentors and reviewers so just
collaborate because then you have
more potential exposure to the content
that you're creating
i've written 10 articles on medium and
have 2 million views
do you recommend me go ahead with a
personal website or continue with medium
i think you can do it everywhere my
articles are on my website they're on my
medium they're on my linkedin
it doesn't take away having them in
different locations i don't think
i think it makes sense for you to keep
it on medium
if you have a personal website do that
you know share on that website that this
specific article has gotten six hundred
thousand views that will encourage
people to want to read it more
if you go to my linkedin profile you'll
see with my cover letter article i added
that in the design it says
50 000 views that's going to encourage
people to want to read it
okay let's um move on
so this is just something that i wanted
to throw out there i wanted to mention
so that you all have awareness
i know this might not be the most
popular part of the presentation
but one of the things that i wanted you
all to think about is that we are
currently in a
very very tight job market um
sometimes when you are pursuing a career
even if it is a mentor or reviewer and
this is your only position
and you want to do something more
related to what you want to do i just
want you to
take a second open your mind
and consider some other career
opportunities that are still in
alignment with what you want to do
so a common conversation that i've been
having with a lot of people lately who
are
in similar positions to you all and even
a student who i had yesterday who is
teaching
an intro to programming course at a
local community college but wants to be
a developer
open your mind to getting involved with
education technology
if you like what udacity stands for if
you
like working for udacity if you enjoy
the experience of helping other people
learn
don't rule that out as an opportunity to
learn there are plenty of opportunities
that
are coming up and are already out there
where companies like uh udacity
companies like
uh udemy companies like um course era
companies
you know colleges and universities are
looking for experts
who want to teach the problem is a lot
of these companies
are high are looking to hire software
engineering instructors
technical curriculum developers and
nobody wants to do that they want to do
the actual job
so a lot of people are asking themselves
why would i
take a 60 000 u.s dollar job to teach
when i could get an 80
000 job doing well if
you're not able to find a job right now
because it's such a tight job market
that's probably a better opportunity
than working part-time and trying
to kind of navigate that depending on
your situation obviously so
i would just consider opening your mind
to additional opportunities within ed
tech
because my background is in k-12 and
higher education
and one of the main reasons why i wanted
to get out of the traditional system is
because i saw
the very very cool things that companies
like udacity was doing
i personally believe that udacity would
be a household name someday i think that
education technology
is going to revolutionize the entire
education industry
i think people will forego university
degrees for programs like this down the
road unless colleges and universities
get to act together
and so for me i see a ton of opportunity
within this
budding industry especially with covid
and all of these schools are like what
are we gonna do
how are we gonna do this online this is
an opportunity
so it may not be ideal but
a lot of us aren't able to live in our
ideal situation right now we have to
look at the reality of
what's going on in the world and we
can't say you know i want to be a
software engineer at google and that's
all i'm going to settle for i think that
that's
being very unrealistic in terms of
thinking about the level of competition
that you're going to face as well as the
amount of opportunities that are open
and available
so that's not to at all discourage you
from pursuing that type of career
i just want you to consider other
options because if you feel like you
like this but want more of the stability
of a full-time role
consider education as a route to kind of
get there because
it could serve as a good kind of place
holder for you the same way that this
role might be
until the job market recovers or until
companies start hiring more developers
and you have that experience that has
supplemented your ability to get that so
just wanted to make a point to to keep
an open mind and explore some of those
opportunities the person i spoke with
yesterday didn't even know
that those opportunities were available
so
just something to take a look at
curriculum developers technical
curriculum developers technical writers
um course instructors
a lot of these programs are not like
udacity where it's self-directed some of
them are actual like
teaching very similar to this on a
consistent basis so just keep an open
mind
um so yeah for those of you who are
still on the call i
really appreciate you listening to me
for this long um i want you all to
um take some time uh brie if you haven't
already please post that graphic within
the student hub channel that you all
share
but i want you to utilize that space to
drop your link please don't just
create a thread i can talk to you from
experience i hate when students go in
and just say
here's my linkedin connect with me and
then you have like 12 in a row
and the content that we're trying to get
out to students gets flooded away with
linkedin messages
so find that graphic and just reply to
it and drop your
linkedin url there and this is a great
opportunity for all of you
to connect with each other on linkedin
because
this is such a valuable resource what
you could be doing and utilizing that
channel for or separate channels
is to support each other's content so um
you know throughout kind of the growth
of social media they
a lot of people will create these things
called pods so either on like instagram
or linkedin
and it's kind of a group of people who
get together and say whenever i post
content
can you support it and so you have a
whole group like 10 people
um we all post content on linkedin every
time we post it we make a note in the
group and then so
everybody can flood that content with
likes and comments to boost the
engagement and boost the awareness
um i would also double check with the
team to make sure that that's okay to
utilize that space
if not you can always create your own
like private chat through like group me
or whatsapp or something like that
um to just support each other because if
you're worried about people not seeing
it
this is a way for you to help each other
but i would say don't sign up to do that
if you
only plan to get help for yourself you
want to make an active effort of going
liking leaving comments and if you're
not able to do that don't expect other
people to do it for you
but it is kind of a quick hack as a way
to get really quick
engagement from your posts so
i would encourage that you utilize each
other and learn who are the other
reviewers in similar areas you may not
be tagging the digital
marketer reviewers for your self-driving
car content you might if they're
interested in that
um but you want those people to to have
an opportunity to engage with you
and boost your awareness and showcase
their expertise as well
um i think you know i've i mentioned a
lot about competition but i think
one of the best ways to compete is to
collaborate with people who are at your
level so that you can
boost each other up as you go i think
there's so much value in being able to
do that for each other
and you know having udacity as a place
to bring all of you together
is really beneficial to where i think
you'll you'll start to get more engaged
with that community as well as just see
some more benefits from that process
um and then you'll also be able to kind
of
you know increase your awareness at the
same time so there's a benefit there
so for those of you who are interested i
would absolutely love everybody to take
a crack
at this um this
is um going to be some people's first
time um
ani if you're not comfortable don't do
it but i want to push you to try
um just to see what happens but ideally
what i'm hoping for
is that you all are able to create a
post
that you know tag me so you'll have to
connect with me first connect with uh
brie and tag us in it you know tag us
towards the end
um and i want you all to just try
and you might be surprised at what
happens um even if it's
fake or it's just us supporting you i
think that it's a great place to start
so that you're getting the hang of doing
it right
but yeah think about your think about
all these things grabbing attention
adding value tagging users using
hashtags readability and timing
um and not to toot my own horn but i'm
going to tweet it just a little bit i
have
over 11 000 followers a lot of them are
in the it space and so just getting
people like me
and bree to comment boost that
engagement right as we looked at the
timeline
people might not be connected to you but
they might be connected to me
so if you create a post about machine
learning and i like it or leave the
comment
that exposes my network potentially to
who you are and may want
and they may want to connect with you
from that i know it's
kind of a little bit difficult to follow
that process
but hopefully it makes a little bit more
sense than it did before this session
but yes i will make sure to comment on
yeah absolutely um if you don't feel
comfortable i totally
get it no pressure at all um but if i
want to i will try
yes okay good good i'm glad thank you
i i appreciate you uh putting forth the
effort
so yes um we
did it in an hour and a half exactly um
thank you all so so much for listening
to me for that long
um i have no problem doing it i could do
it all day
um but yeah i want to set some time
aside for you all to
ask any questions that you might have
and this is a great time for you to ask
more personal questions
um and not like your personal life but
like things that relate specifically to
your situation i like to try to keep the
comments relevant throughout the
presentation but i have i'm in no rush
to hop off the call
um so if you do have any questions that
you're wondering about
please feel free to do that i would also
encourage you to check out that resource
on udacity's youtube page
of all of the events the i will say this
the career coaching team with udacity is
the best team i've i've worked with as
it relates to career development
and just the the level of expertise i
think
usc has done an amazing job of
collecting experts in that area
so we've got like a list of like 55 plus
events
similar to this but not necessarily
targeted for
mentors but targeted for job seekers
that i think you'll find really valuable
um and i've done a lot of those events
myself if you just
like the content that i've shared it can
be very similar but yeah
any questions feel free to jump on your
mic uh feel free to
put it in the chat i'm here to help
brett hi hello hi
um apart from like the usual like
linkedin and medium
do you post on any other channels
that you find valuable to
um to you for example good question
so i think it may look different for you
um and i'd say i usually tell that to
everybody like
for people who are artists linkedin is
not
the best place instagram is better for
that so i do
um i have done some instagram in the
past just because i have a different
following there
i have a lot of friends from high school
in college
and people who know me more from my
personal life and just you know
knowing me as a person and not
necessarily my work so sometimes i will
post content on instagram
i've been taking kind of a huge social
media break
lately so i haven't posted on there very
frequently but i do have some success
through
instagram but i've had to be very aware
of that content obviously on linkedin
long form text works really well for me
medium is long form text
but on instagram i can't post you know a
screenshot of a resume and say hire me i
have to do more video
i have to do more images more graphics
and things like that so you want to be
aware of like where your audience
is and engaged and what makes the most
sense for your area of expertise
um so for me personally um i would say
most of my content is either on linkedin
uh medium or instagram or live
like events like this i love to do
webinars and so i deal with them
frequently with my business
and i get a lot of engagement through
the live session so even if it's not
social media
i think public speaking can can be a
really great opportunity for that as
well
cool thank you yeah whole webinar by the
way
um very interesting yeah i'm glad you
got some value from it
uh let's see carlos what is the tag for
oh so you have to connect with us on
linkedin first so
um i mean you could just type in um my
name and search udacity it should pop up
hopefully
um and brie maybe you can drop yours in
there um
let's see what else have you thought
about starting your own consultancy
company and going fully independent
i mean your own one-man company so i am
doing that um it is
i've i started off as a freelance resume
writer and
as i grew i've never touched that money
for personal
use i always pour it back into the
business as well as
taking on additional certifications i
transitioned from
freelance resume writer once i realized
that resume was less important than
networking in linkedin i started
focusing on coaching
after doing some coaching i've done a
little bit of consulting for
college university career centers as
well as doing webinar series for their
students
and just doing some public speaking as
well that's kind of where i'm at right
now
obviously with the pandemic things have
slowed down a little bit for me but yeah
i've been doing it it's been fun it's
been a wild ride
um but yeah if anybody's interested in
that i think it can be a great
experience for you all as well
but yeah any last questions or anybody
want to jump on their mic
hey i got a question please okay sure
the target is to engage the contacts or
some
kind of head hunters that may follow
the post that are out so inside the
network or outside the network
so um let me i want to make sure i
understand your question so you're
asking like
is the is the target to connect with
people in your network or outside of
your network
yes it's the target of the post so do
you i post something
i want to be seen from people of my
network or somebody else that is outside
of the network
some kind of had hundreds of some other
people
yeah great question so i think it's a
little bit of both right you want to
create content in general and i don't
think you have to target it specifically
to fit that
because you will get new followers or
new connections based on the content
that you're creating
so one is you want to build
an audience by sharing content but you
also want to cater to the audience that
you already have
so in terms of putting out content i
don't think that it changes too too much
because if you're creating quality
content it should be relevant to both
your already connected people and people
who are finding it
by you know other people's engagement so
you win
both of those areas by creating content
in general
i hope that answers your question well
let's see question what is the best way
to target the audience outside your
country
so i think you have to start by building
connections within that location
it's going to be really difficult for
you to start targeting those people
if all of your connections are in the
same location so for me
i never really attracted people
in like um india in like nigeria
or two places that i never really had
people but once i started to get more
professionals
in those locations i started to get more
connections from people in those
locations
so i would say you have to start by you
know either connecting with them first
or potentially creating content that's
relevant for them so one of the things
that i'm constantly thinking about when
i'm putting together content for udacity
is that
i'm not just speaking to a us audience
i'm not just speaking to a local
audience i'm speaking to a global
audience and so i have to
try my best to use what i do know and to
make it
applicable for people in a wide variety
of industries as well as
globally so if i was trying to
target people in the uk one of the
things that i might do
is you know there are some there are
some slight differences in language
between the us
english and you know uh british english
and then also you know there may be
certain hiring standards that are very
different in some countries
having your picture on your resume is
either required or recommended
and in the u.s that's kind of like a
no-go don't do that
or you don't need it so i would have to
be familiar with the customs and the
culture and different things like that
so that i could you know make sure that
i'm i'm
creating content that that fits that so
i would say it's going to take some time
to educate yourself and do some research
sometimes linkedin makes me feel low i
see people's success and it really makes
me feel unworthy what can i do about
that
i feel really uncomfortable that is very
common
so that idea you know is called social
comparison
and people do it on all different
platforms in all different forms
i've myself kind of caught myself doing
that especially on platforms like
linkedin
where i'm scrolling through and i'm like
why doesn't why don't i look like that
when i go to the gym
or you know like this isn't working for
me
um and so that's the same thing with
platforms like linkedin you know i don't
think it's beneficial for you to compare
yourself to other people unless that's a
motivator for you
if you're finding that you're getting
more stress from it than motivation
take a break or re-evaluate how you look
at that platform i think that
that's not going to do a lot for you in
terms of benefiting you because then it
starts to cloud your judgment and what
making decisions that are right for you
so when you start to see what other
people are doing you start to think
that's what i should be doing
and your situation your life your your
really your unique situation is not the
same as theirs
so they may you know you may have a
family they may be single
and they may be looking at your life and
saying i wish i had a family like they
do
the same way you're saying i wish i have
a job like they do you don't see the
behind the scenes you don't see what
goes into that you don't see that
they're working
70 hours a week to have that job that
you want where you really are enjoying
kind of having the comfort of your
family and different things like that so
don't do that it's going to make it
harder for you to decide what you really
want because basically you're deciding
what you want based on what other people
have
and that process needs to start
internally um
yes imposter syndrome is is serious um
so yeah i i don't usually make
recommendations for for therapy but i
i've done it myself you know i'm not
ashamed
to say so i've gotten a lot of value
from speaking to a therapist speaking to
other career coaches
i think that there's a huge stigma
around mental health and i don't know
why i
i love going to the therapist every
single time i go i'm excited
um i don't always leave in the best mood
but i always find it valuable and
helpful for me to do so
um so yeah i definitely think that's
something that you can work through and
something that
you know starts from within not from
externally but yeah
a great recommendation so yeah i do want
to wrap up
um thank you all so so much for
participating thank you all
for um engaging and thank you all for
the great
great questions and sharing some of your
insights as well
um thank you bri for helping facilitate
this
i had a great time working with you all
um i enjoy doing this um brie is there
anything that you
wanted to to say or close out with um
no i think you did an amazing job thank
you everyone for showing
up i'll still be in student hub doing
office hours
uh later today and um i'll be following
up with you guys on your
uh questions and stuff so thank you for
showing up and thank you
all right well yeah i guess well with
that um we will close out once again
thank you all for attending i wish you
all the best of luck whether it's your
job search or any personal branding
things
um if you have any specific questions or
want additional content check out that
career webinars playlist we have a ton
of great stuff on there from
all of the coaching team you know great
experts and
a lot of knowledge on there that isn't
always used to its fullest extent so
um check that out once again thank you
all i hope you have a great rest of your
morning afternoon night wherever that
looks like for you
but bye